un paso importante para reforzar el
matrimonio igualitario en Estados Unidos
la cámara de representantes aprobó un
proyecto de ley que protege estas
uniones a nivel Federal un debate
acalorado se vivió en la sala Este es
otro paso más hacia la meta de los
demócratas de desmantelar la familia
tradicional silenciar las voces de la fe
y deshacer permanentemente el cimiento
de nuestro país tejido por Dios sería
incorrecto decir que mi esposo fill y yo
tenemos un matrimonio que es diferente
al matrimonio de cualquier otra persona
aquí en este cuerpo el seguro de salud
de mi centro de trabajo debe extenderse
a mi esposo al igual que el suyo se
extiende a su cónyuge la aprobación fue
aplastante así lo dio a conocer Nancy
pelosi en uno de sus últimos actos como
presidenta de la cámara
en esta votación los sí son 258 los no
son 169 se adopta la moción
la medida surgió de las preocupaciones
que generan un posible revés de la Corte
Suprema a este tipo de uniones como
ocurrió con legislación que permitía la
interrupción del embarazo el proyecto
promueve que el Gobierno Federal
reconozca el matrimonio entre dos
personas del mismo sexo si es legal en
el estado donde se casaron y además se
reconoce la libertad de religiosa tras
la aprobación el presidente Joe biden no
tardó en reaccionar en este día Jill y
yo estamos pensando en las parejas
valientes y los defensores
apasionadamente comprometidos que han
luchado durante décadas para garantizar
la igualdad en el matrimonio en todo el
país ante la Corte Suprema y en el
congreso si bien estamos un paso más
cerca de nuestro largo viaje para
construir una Unión más perfecta nunca
debemos dejar de luchar por la igualdad
total para los estadounidenses lgtbiq+ y
todos nuestros ciudadanos la ley fue
ratificada por el senado el mes pasado
ahora deberá ir al despacho oval para su
aprobación final por parte del
presidente Joe biden para que entre en
vigor